l'histoire d'une équipe qui termine en
beauté alors que les débuts souvenez
vous nous avez fait si peur c'est une
première dans l'histoire du handball
les bleus ont remporté consécutivement
les jeux olympiques le championnat du
monde et ce soir le championnat d'europe
qui aurait rêvé mieux
un vrai bonheur raconté par mathieu
méranville endroits du monde et de
toutes les galaxies les experts de
vienne de miami de becker est d'ailleurs
gagne tout depuis trois saisons
champions olympiques du monde qui est
maintenant d'europe je crois que dans
l'abîmé culte l équipe a montré toutes
ses ressources
contrairement à ce que certains disent
elles n'étaient pas vieillissante
à l'époque on a encore plein de choses à
découvrir plein de choses à gagner
et pourtant les croates avaient débuté
le match sur les chapeaux de roue avec
un halilovic impérial dans les bus et
des attaquants qui tout réussissait
les français s'accroche tant bien que
mal avec sorento qui égalise mais très
vite les joueurs à damiers se détache
grâce à vos rides notamment en fin de mi
temps
karabatic sonne la révolte et contre
toute attente les bleus égalisent grâce
à l'art 6 12 12 à la mi temps
alinovi de rentrer aux vestiaires fou de
rage la deuxième période voit débute un
tout autre match
karabatic impulser le mouvement les
tricolores prennent davantage
définitivement abalo malchance en
première période
plane au dessus de la défense croate
intenable le jeune attaquant seront des
angles impossibles qui finissent par
écoeurer halilovic mais karabatic malgré
son ascendance pro hat n'a pas de pitié
pour les joueurs venus de la patrie de
son père
il scelle le score du match score final
25 21 les bleus réalisent une passe de
trois historiques